CBS News is learning new details in the
mysterious case of a missing mother in
Colorado
Kelsey Barrett disappeared more than two
months ago while her fiance Patrick
Frazee is charged with murder
well now crystal Lee in Idaho nurse is
at the center of a cover-up
investigation she pleaded guilty Friday
to tampering with evidence in the case
and in an interview you'll see only on
CBS this morning Niki batiste sat down
with Lee's close friend and confidante
she shares why she believes Lee admitted
to helping Frazee tried to hide
Barrett's death Niki good morning good
morning good morning everyone
1al crystal Lee is a key witness in this
case
she's known Patrick Frazee for 15 years
and the two previously dated but one of
her closest friends says it was only
recently that Lee discovered Frazee had
been engaged to another woman kelsey
Bharath and that the pair had a child
together do you think Patrick's a
murderer yes I do I think he's a very
dangerous person
Michelle Steen says her close friend
crystal Lee confided in her about her
role in covering up Kelsey Barrett's
death we sat down with Steen in Twin
Falls Idaho where the two women live has
crystal ever said that she's been
fearful of him at any point yes what did
she say she did tell me that she has
never seen that kind of evil in anybody
Bharath a 29 year old pilot vanished on
Thanksgiving Day in Colorado and was
last seen in this surveillance video
shopping with the one-year-old daughter
she and her fiance Patrick Frazee shared
investigators say three days later
Bharath cell phone pinged nearly 600
miles away in gooding Idaho about an
hour from Lee's home two text messages
were sent one to Baris employer saying
she would be away for a week and another
to freezy take me to the first moment
crystal told you that Patrick Frazee had
tried to involve her in this crime I
will just tell you crystal was very very
scared Crystal's a very level-headed
kind fun-loving happy-go-lucky person
she's she's a tough cowgirl but she was
absolutely scared and extremely upset on
Friday Lee admitted she dumped Bharath
cell phone just two days after birth
death and claimed she knew Frazee had
already killed Beth she had very very
good reasoning for whatever it is she
may or may not have done what was the
reasoning I can't really comment
completely but fear and legitimate fear
that if she didn't comply with Patrick
he might kill her yes that's what I
believe yes Stein says Lee and Frazee a
blacksmith met after high school at a
ranch and bonded over horses were they
in a sexual relationship recently I
don't want to call in AMA Frazee is
currently in jail without bail
authorities believe he murdered Bharath
at her home but they have not determined
a clear motive and her body still has
not been found as a part of her plea
sources tells CBS news Lee is expected
to testify against Frazee and possibly
reveal but Frazee told her about Bharath
you have no doubt Christian absolutely
no doubt whatsoever Lee is not in
custody but faces up to three years in
prison when she's sentenced CBS News has
reached out to Lee's attorney but has
not heard back Frazee's preliminary
hearing is scheduled for February 19th
and we hope to finally hear some of the
evidence in this case which has all been
suppressed and Kelsey and Patrick's
daughter Hayley is with Kelsey's parents
yes that's right right Nikki thank you